yes what place what does he do that what
is the movie about you haven't read the
scene no um I I honestly just think that
the movie like at its simplest in most
detail is about three lost souls living
in New York and I do think it's that
specific to New York and I mean that it
can kind of be a universal thing about
three archetypes and all that kind of
stuff but but I think use that specific
which is why my which is my my quite
might work in resonate elsewhere nothing
when you get that specific about a
location and a generation or three
different generations things start to
branch out and become Universal but yeah
I do think it's just about sinking three
most people kind of searching for
something as a naughty oh well I'm I'm
from so high please I was talking about
my life as an Aussie I like he called me
Ozzie which is nice no beer no travelled
or much I don't I've always been me
personally I've always been putting
myself in different situations and
different scenes in different people
it's not I don't know as soon as we got
to New York I mean Mark had me my
research was to go out and party with
the girls into that my frame kind of
find it inside yourself rather than out
and then you find
like you know the New York right no New
Yorkers identity I think having you know
having mark and as our August dragon
that really you know I think it added to
it to that you're kind of you didn't
have fake like it wasn't like family
were over in Brooklyn or something it
was kind of like gave you made you all
feel like loners you know even yeah
exactly
it can be so it was hard to make them
likable these girls because some of them
especially your character is a few
scenes I was a bartender for a long time
she's screaming at those wait till you
see this because there's like a ten
minute monologue I do she become very
likable once the camera comes and I
think you you both transmits and I think
that what was great was you almost
become polar opposites in some way
because you it seems like you were able
to let go of being like the strong like
Savior want and actually kind of grieve
about what had happened to you and then
I thought you just became more sort of
calm and like just not so angry about
things so interesting because I played
the opposite one thing one things inside
of you and but we were talking about how
when the camera comes they connect I
wonder that they could be more
themselves because well I think for
violet she wants she wants her life on a
big screen I mean she's got nothing like
this so they're in so much pain both of
them I think pilots about dealing with
it is to use to just affect everyone
around her and try and get either
conflict a lot or something from other
people
yeah I felt like I found the camera
really interesting because I actually
think you know I think in a way I didn't
think this when were filming it but for
much of my film I felt like the first
time it's kind of John's gift to the
girls is documenting themselves I mean I
know you think he's horrible but I think
no yeah the camera starts yeah it does
start their grading process and for the
first time they kind of have to you know
have something to show for themselves
and how much of it did you get to improv
when the camera was up I mean did it was
it all completely scripted or did you
guys have a little bit of play time with
us we had the things that we had
playtime like we basically improvised
into the scenes so that it was seamless
the way that it looked but and then we
improvised after the scenes and there's
a lot of that stuff ease in the special
features because mark can really just
cut me right but it made but what he
wrote ended up we ended up coming around
back to it even then we try to discover
other ways of doing it because how he
wrote was actually the best way to say
what we wanted to say most naturally and
it just came out that way in the end so
yeah I came it was really fascinating
because we during the rehearsal period
we kind of play around with the dialogue
and find you know coming piece around in
ourselves and then by the time we were
filming we would literally say to the
correctly lon yeah because helium to the
arm when it comes to the character of
John I'm really curious to know what
your guys this first like like thoughts
of that character was when you remember
the script every kid said how how reads
any
but I was just curious about your own
thoughts on that character and then how
Reeves brought him to life like was it
different than what you originally
thought that character would become yeah
I think I think John said I just think
he's he's frustrating but he's also
someone in your life do you know what I
mean he's stagnant and know him you know
and I I really like that about about his
character is dirty he's not really
moving but throughout the course of the
film you know as the camera did for the
girls he covered the first time Hector
had to have some kind of wave document
you know something to document I was
really freaked out by by the character
of violet so I didn't even pay attention
to be on who's gonna say that okay it
was just it was just but to be honest
with you I didn't have any pretty
preconceived ideas of what he would do I
really didn't I just kind of read love
what he did and it was yeah sorry what
was more style of giving you notes like
when he had a scene like what was his
way cuz he was used to doing
documentaries right so he want to be
script you know to come to life and it
was it was
it wasn't like he has hands it was over
it was it was really interesting here
and speak to you would give us each each
very separate direction and secretive
secretly like so he'd take you away and
give you a note and what actually ended
up happening was you didn't really you
didn't benefit from the direction as
much as the other ticket because it was
also you know they were very action from
it was super fabulous I've never I
didn't even know how he directed you I
think most of the work is done in the
rehearsal actually which was like this
kind of hallway conversation between
like the actors in him and and and there
was a real understanding that he wanted
his words to be spoken and but we could
improvise and I think by being that
willing to allow us to own them we
actually we actually owned his words and
made them our own either end of either
end of each scene yeah I think nine
times yeah we I mean a team and I argue
w I have to say I don't know him and I
argued a bit and I was just challenged
by it but that was awesome because it
made everything so so much better it
really did I think that those kind of
relationships actually benefit rather
than rather than not and yes and they
board the bus care and we both have
opinions and you know how much rehearsal
time did you have you can for that too
like big films and then both of them do
share what's up Gatsby coming outside
hey did you prefer a smaller film like
this or would give more time actually
and who is actually I arrived yeah but
it was it was really great because it
just meant that we could we could be as
open as I think we both craved to be
which is hard like yeah it will be
higher you know we young and women young
actresses and coming and working with a
superstar and it could be so it will be
so easy for him to kind of be you know
and be like this is what we're gonna do
and for us to go yes yeah
could you talk about the relationship
between your two characters and what it
was like playing off each other um we
can just look at each other and you can
feel it yeah it was amazing yeah I think
I think I think me and violet are just
so interesting because they they you
know they kind of shift between
roommates and sisters and then
mother-daughter and then it's what kind
of it flips around and yeah I found I
think it was rid of what was really
funny was I know that I personally felt
like the whole time that Mia was in
control of the situation and the
territory whereas I'm I'm very sure that
Miami thought that she was I thought I
was in control not even violent me
laughing no Keanu annoyance dub we just
got the giggle fit and I'm mark just
started rolling in it's actually ended
up in the films because the because the
repercussions of that and beyond Mia
yeah just really fascinating I mean it
was always it's a power play there's
power play the whole way through the
film we had yeah and I think I actually
kind of think that when we all met the
dynamic between us formed the characters
I don't think you could deny that
because we've that's how we had to work
we were we had to bring our self our
reality of who we were like Boyan and
Keanu and anyway
yeah and there was this I mean we
rehearse there was you know budget we
rehearse that dance that we do at the
end at my place like in my lounge room
no I knew it was a really awkward thing
guy right here it was just really odd
but that's kind of the way you just
waited yeah and I mean and the way that
the way that the set word was that
everyone was in each other's space
there's key on him in the corner there's
me like going boy who's attention all
the crew in this one apartment we had
actually we had the the top apartment is
now it's a bit like a baby's cot was you
know yeah was the white glass a of a
happy accident he doesn't have any
reservations about how spots the script
was because well we only do so much and
a lot of apparently don't get to see you
art was there anything specific that you
were able to bring to this movie that
wasn't in the script it seems like this
is a movie that would demand a lot from
the actors in it
you know I think that markets really
ugly once it was cast math was really
open to us very much bringing ourselves
I mean it's a really strange room to
talk about because you can talk about
one aspect you can talk about all the
generate and really the generational
things like the social things like
generation on what does that mean what
is that generation who are we you know
what is media and you know Internet and
Technology have to you know what part
does that have to play in the way that
we communicate the way we deny our pain
and our feelings and all that stuff and
then what kind of healings do we become
and how to be interact with each other
but then there's also this other layer
which is that we had to like really dig
very deep into who we work to be able to
find characters and that's a whole other
kind of narcissistic actors Germany and
for me it was very much about going
about really seriously playing the
person that I couldn't clean if I didn't
stop drinking seven years ago which I
did stop and very much like that was
absolutely my part and so for me
personally I just brought that I had to
bring myself which I've never done and
no one would know that because I mean
maybe you guys I'm talking a drinker
wouldn't would go my god that's like
she's crazy there's nothing like whoa
where did that come from
but it came from who I would absolutely
unequivocally be fine you had stayed on
that path she remains the mysterious
quiet one scene Mia where you just
talked about what men want what children
want was were those marks lines or
I think I don't know I find Mia
you know we were looking at her
character we actually saw that you know
a lot of her characteristics
corresponding directly with a sociopath
so a lot of what she speaks is you know
is it's just trying to create a reaction
and and and play and play with both John
and and I think especially for that so
yeah she has a strange relationship with
the truth than what she perceives to be
the truth what she you know where she
strives to be and where she's out all
right